випадковість чи провокація уперше після
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в
Україну російський літак зіткнувся з
американським безпілотником один із пари
російських винищувачів су-27 врізався в
розвідувальний Дрон США mq-9 ріпер над
акваторією чорного
моряком playings вже були схожі
інциденти з британськими розвідувальними
літаками теж на Чорне море що призвело
до призупинення розвідувальних місій
британських літаків але вперше сталося
зіткнення в повітрі що робить інцидент
небезпечним з точки зору ескалації
російські пілоти повелися значно
агресивніше ніж зазвичай взаємні
перехоплення і супроводження літаків це
звичайна практика вже протягом багатьох
років такі перехоплення трапляються але
це відрізняється своєю агресивністю
у пентагоні роз'яснили деталі російські
пілоти небезпечно маневрували перед
дроном і скидали пальне намагаючись
погіршити видимість для безпілотника або
пошкодити його водночас у американського
оборонного відомства поки немає даних
про те що росіянам вдалося знайти збитий
безпілотник
що вивчаємо те що сталося але виходячи з
дій російських пілотів очевидно що Вони
діяли небезпечно і непрофесійно думаю
результат говорить сам за себе ми бачили
що винищувач скидав авіапальне перед
безпілотником а потім підійшов так
близько що пошкодили гвинт mq9 за нашими
оцінками внаслідок цього російське
винищувач теж зазнав пошкоджень
російськими оборони заявило що їхні
винищувачі не причетні до падіння дрона
апосол РФ у Штатах якого викликали в
держдепартамент заявив що вважає
інцидент провокацією
[оплески]
не було контакту не було використання
ніякого озброєння нашими винищувачами
и что вот этот і цей безпілотний
літальний апарат виконавши різкий
розворот врізався в простір
апарат летів з вимкненими транспондерами
і увійшов у зону яку було визначено як
зону спеціальної військової операції за
міжнародними каналами ми Росія
попередили всіх про це Я вважаю що це
справжня провокація Я читаю что это
настоящие Провокация провокацією але з
російського боку вважає інцидент-експерт
з питань безпеки томка раку
сенс лайк
усе напевно виглядає так ніби російський
Пілот крутився навколо дрона І навмисно
намагався знищити як заявляється
американський безпілотник q9 над Чорним
морем Отже це провокація щось схоже на
тест росіянам звісно не подобається що
ми літаємо над міжнародними водами і
вони цілком очевидно висловлюють своє
невдоволення
натомість британський фахівець Майк
Мартін не певен Що росіяни навмисне
атакували американський Дрон
для Росії звична справа супроводжувати
розвідувальні літальні апарати вони
роблять це і щодо британських літаків на
Північним морем не думаю що росіяни
хотіли збити американський безпілотник
радше через залякування і супроводження
на близькій відстані стався прорахунок
американський літак довелося приводний
день
демократичної більшості в американському
сенатік шумер наголосив що Сполучені
Штати регулярно здійснюють польоти на
Чорне морем і робитимуть це надалі
сенатор застаріг російську сторону від
ескалації
Це ще один безрозсудний вчинок
президента Путіна та його військових я
хочу сказати пану Путіну припиніть таку
поведінку перш ніж ви станете причиною
ненавмисно ескалації Ми бачили таку
поведінку російських військових раніше І
це не стримає Сполучені Штати від
проведення операції на Чорне море
ці агресивні дії російської авіації є
ризикованими і можуть призвести повторюю
до ненавмисної ескалації
[музика]
раніше американські дрони моніторили
лінію розмежування на Донбасі нині
безпілотники США практично щодня літають
на Чорне морем зазначили в українських
повітряних силах з лютого 2022 року
розвідувальна інформація яку збирають
такі літальні апарати стала особливу
цінною для українських військових
у будь-який момент часу від 6 до 10
літальних апаратів НАТО перебувають у
повітряному просторі сусідніх з Україною
держав вони всі зв'язуються між собою
прослуховуючи російські комунікації ця
інформація збирається аналізується і
передається українським військовим аби
вони могли ефективно відпрацьовувати
цілі якщо пам'ятаєте на початку війни
Росія втратила 20-30 генералів у
короткий період часу усе завдяки Ось
таким діям те що росіяни втрачають менше
генералів зараз означає що вони зробили
свої системи комунікацій більш
захищеними
mq9 Reaper один із найпоширеніших Дронів
він може нести ракети Але той що впав у
Чорне море як повідомили в пентагоні
займався саме розвиткою і спостереженням
над міжнародними водами
На жаль росіяни вважають Чорне море
своїм озером з юридичної точки зору це
міжнародні води Росії може не подобатися
Цей факт але з точки зору міжнародного
права це захищає Сполучені Штати від
будь-яких звинувачень у порушенні
російського повітряного простору
ключове питання чи при де інцидент у
Чорному морі до ескалації між США і
Росією і Кремлі Вашингтон не раз
демонстрували що не бажають прямого
зіткнення через це аналітики
американського інституту вивчення війни
вважають що причин для небезпечної
ескалації немає такої думки дотримуються
й опитані ДВ експерти
уявити більшу ескалацію у цій війні і ще
гірше відносини Росії США ніж вони є
нині як ми бачимо зокрема зі слів
російського посла обидві сторони не
роблять чимало галасу з приводу цієї
ситуації потім вони все ж прагнуть
переступити через цей епізод і рухатися
далі
їх риторику росіянам думаю варто
заспокоїтися і припинити агресивні
перехоплення на Чорне морем у
міжнародному повітряному просторі аби не
було ескалації особливо якщо це буде
стосуватися пілото ваних літальних
апаратів ось тут є можливості для
ескалації про яку варто непокоїтися
тим часом Невдовзі після інциденту у
Чорному морі німецький британський
винищувачі перехопили російський іл-78 а
потім і ан-148 неподалік повітряного
простору Естонії уперше таку операцію
спільно провели повітряні сили двох
держав НАТО